And the answer here is clearly that halt of inverse halt and inverse halt returns no,
because that is the way that we constructed inverse halt. So if inverse halt receives an input,
it only terminates if halt of the program as a program and the program as the input returns no.
Otherwise, it would have gone into an infinite loop. And now let's think for a second about what that means.
So halt of inverse halt and inverse halt says no. The first time inverse halt is a program, and the second time here,
it's the input. So what halt's saying no basically means is the following:
If I take inverse halt and give it inverse halt as an input, then this does not terminate, because halt says no,
and we assume that halt is a correct algorithm. But that's a bit strange, isn't it?
But now wait a minute: We just said that running the program inverse halt of inverse halt actually halts.
But when we look at the implication of this, then it tells us that inverse halt, when run on inverse halt, does not halt.
So, something doesn't seem quite right here. Which one is it? Does it stop or does it not stop?
Before we go deeper into that, let's ask the question exactly the other way around.